I would like to know more about how the pancreatitis cancer is treated.
So, pancreatic cancer is treated, I would like to, I would like a lot more about vitamins
and how to use that with other medications.
Okay, so pancreatic cancer is just a one form of cancer.
How was it treated from a oncological standpoint?
They're definitely going to use pretty heavy dose chemotherapy with that.
And there's a certain type of surgery that they do with pancreatic cancer if you're
a candidate for that, depends on what it looks like on the CT and MRI.
From a natural standpoint, pancreatic cancer is treated differently depending on who you
go to.
So, if you use, there's lots of different natural approach to cancer.
So, in my book, I talk about making sure you get tested for how to treat it.
There's lots of different natural cancer treatments that can be extremely beneficial, but not for
everybody.
And what are you going to choose to do?
You know, you search cancer treatment, alternative cancer treatment, and you can get bombarded
with information that may not apply to you.
So we do cheek swab testing in our office that makes us quite unique, so we get specific
in our protocols.
But just to be honest, it's everybody's different.
We help people with pancreatic cancer that are, you know, every single person is on a completely
different protocol.
If you go to our stop by the cancer course, it does give you some ideas of different
protocols, things to start with.
One of the common protocols with pancreatic cancer would be using enzyme therapy.
So you're using fairly high-dose enzymes, pancreatic enzymes that you take an empty stomach
to help break down the slime layer around a growing cancer so that your immune system can
get at it.
But you also have to couple that with the immune stimulation therapy.
We use rife therapy, you know, I highly recommend that for everybody that's doing, that has
a chance, any kind of cancer diagnosis, the beautiful thing about the rife is that I believe
that it really helps, if you're doing chemotherapy, helps the chemotherapy target the cancer,
better so you're going to have, I think better results.
I think years down the road, if we're still here, and the Lord doesn't tarry, that I think
the rife will be used by oncologists to help chemotherapy target cancer.
But as far as you said, I'd like to, I'd like a lot more, I'd like to maybe learn a lot
more about vitamins and how to use them with other medications.
So there are some interactions.
If you're going to go, you know, using chemotherapy, you don't, if you're going to use chemotherapy,
you don't want to use antioxidant antioxidants as far as supplements go.
So your oncologist would, would state that to you, I hope.
So you make sure you tell your oncologists if you're doing, if you're doing about just supplements
that you decided to pick out, if you're going to do chemotherapy, you don't want to take
out antioxidants, at least for 48 hours, after you do the chemotherapy, chemotherapy is
a oxidative agent.